remember anybody who wants to
participate name and location as your
nickname if you have only one or the
other I will be unable to call on you
let's go uh next to Noah from New York
Noah from New York welcome
hey David good to talk to you I'm uh
I've been watching you uh for a while so
a little nervous but thank you for
bringing me on well so far you're doing
great your audio is good so we're off to
a good start really
thank you I had I had to really look
around the settings figure out how to
turn off the Discord notifications good
uh anyway no I would say um I got a
question for you it's just a little more
of a silly question it's not too serious
because we can't really know it's like
you know what would you do in a zombie
apocalypse type stuff right
um I'm just curious I want to kick this
back and forth with you how do you think
um what's happening if climate change is
going to pan out we're not going to
clearly avoid it we're not doing nearly
enough uh what do you think the end
result of all this is going to be I mean
the damage what's what's gonna happen
how it's going to affect our dialogue
and politics moving forward what do you
think it's so difficult to say and we're
so terrible at predicting things so let
me give you one claim that's made and
then I and which I don't believe and
then we'll back up from it there are
some who say listen I don't deny that
what climatologists have identified is
real and it's coming I just am confident
that science and engineering is go going
to be able to keep up to prevent it from
ever really getting that bad okay that's
something some people say I don't
subscribe to that I don't subscribe to
that however I do think that after there
is a bunch of Damage Done by climate
change and we're already starting to see
it we see pollution deaths we see sea
level rising in certain places
increasingly underwater like we're
already seeing it but I think after
there is some significant damage from
climate change I think then much of the
world will kick it into high gear and
yes it'll be too little too late but it
will speed up to a degree that then we
can say now we're making some progress
but it'll be after a bunch of damage is
done that that's my genuine prediction
like once things really actually start
to get bad
yeah that's what I thought too is that
like you're not really going to see it
taken seriously until you get issues
with like a climate refugees and mass
migration to a lot of you know what we
call First World countries or damage
there that and the thing is a lot of
people are going to hear our
conversation Noah and they'll say but
guys that's already happening and I
don't deny that but I'm saying it's
going to have to be more it's gonna have
to be more yeah it's going to be massive
yeah I think do you think you're going
to see like um almost some crackdowns on
like those who have opposed or do a pose
it and uh and generally do you think
like like I'm talking like authoritarian
situation because I do Wonder this like
if things get very bad and desperate are
you gonna see like hard-line measures
taken by governments that are going to
cause like pushback and stuff absolutely
there are countries that already lean
more authoritarian the countries that
lean more authoritarian whenever we get
to this imaginary point that I'm talking
about I think you will see some very
hard line action by some governments uh
but you will have to wait and see
exactly what governments which
governments those are at that time
yeah and how they'll go all right and
one last thing um do you think people
who are like hardcore denying it are
ever going to come around or do you
think there's probably still going to be
like a block that are just going to
convince themselves that it's like
antifa changing the weather yeah there
will always be people who who believe
it's jet geoengineering or something
like that
all right listen no before right before
I let you go can you off the off your
the top of your head can you name four
countries that start with the letter L
um let's say
Lithuania uh yeah man you're putting me
on the spot here so now it's like it's
like when people are asked to name a
book yeah they're like name any book and
they're like oh God which book are so
many I mean Lithuanian
Liechtenstein I would have also accepted
Luxembourg Latvia and Laos yeah
there we go yeah yeah that's fine all
right Noah thank you for the call
appreciate it all right you too take
care take care there's Noah from New
York uh bringing up some sad but
relevant and important issues I have to
say